[Music]
after 9/11 Sikhs become target of hate
crime and we felt a need to do something
at that point I thought how can we
interact with other communities other
people from different faiths and educate
people who seek so we thought well as
far the motorcycle group my dad gives
people a point of view that is different
that we aren't bad guys we are good guys
[Music]
the Sikh riders of America are a turban
wearing motorcycle group that travels
the country educating people about the
Sikh religion the group was formed in
2012 after a gunman into the Sikh temple
and killed six people an estimated is
about 250,000 Sikhs living in the United
States there's a large portion of our
American neighbors who doesn't know who
the Sikhs are Sikh religion believes in
equality to all and then service to
others I have experience I hate just
because I'm a Sikh and I look different
riding a motorcycle is one of the big
American dream
Sikhs are known warriors in India we
were always riding horses and so
motorcycles are modern-day horses that's
one of the reason we want to start so
you have something in common
each year the Sikh riders of America put
on fundraisers to raise money for local
charities the fund raisers center around
leading community motorcycle rides to
local parks were in turn people
experience food dance and traditions
from Sikh culture and Gurinder is making
sure to pass his work down to the next
generation my plan has been taken apart
in Sikh riders in America since he was
six years old he has gone to homeless
shelters to feed the homeless I think it
would be really great if I'd be able to
pass it on to my son seeing my dad do
those things makes me feel proud of my
dad I think what my dad does for the
less fortunate inspires me to do the
same so I can follow his lead it's
everyone's event you're all a part of us
because without you we haven't been able
to do it thank you
I personally have seen many people after
they met us they learn about our
religion and who we are they have
changed their view of looking at us we
have made a big impact on the
communities we live in and we have been
able to educate people cross America
[Music]